y en france 24 y en directo américa lo
que queremos es que usted entienda un
poco más de esta situación cómo se
origina cuáles son todos los factores
involucrados y por eso entonces me
acompaña en este momento en el estudio
andrés espinales en nuestro jefe uno de
nuestros jefes de reacción de frança 24
en español andrés es un gusto tenerlo
acá en el estudio pues muy bien aquí
trabajando pues no hemos parado de
trabajar desde las 2 de la mañana que
llegamos acá y por eso lo tenemos aquí
usted hablemos un poco de las
autoproclamadas repúblicas de unidad y
lugar son el meollo de todo esto las
protagonistas exacto vamos a tratar de
explicar y de entender pues como sé cuál
es el contexto de esta situación y cómo
llegamos hasta acá tenemos que recordar
el contexto en febrero de 2014 durante
la llamada revolución del maidán el
entonces presidente ucraniano víctor
yanukóvich cuyo hacia rusia y poco
después moscú anexo la península de
crimea y también al mismo tiempo apoyó a
los separatistas del este entonces éstos
hicieron la autoproclamación de las
repúblicas de donges y de lugansk y
vamos a verlas en el mapa si producción
nos ayuda con
la imagen aquí la tenemos vamos a hablar
un poco de ellas poco a poco la
república
popular de unidas que tiene
aproximadamente ocho mil 900 kilómetros
cuadrados y más de 2 millones de
habitantes la república popular de
lugares que tiene unos 8.300 kilómetros
cuadrados y más de un millón y medio de
personas desde 2014 los separatistas han
estado enfrentados con el ejército
ucraniano en un conflicto que ha cobrado
ya la vida de más o menos 15 mil
personas y ucrania considera que estas
zonas son básicamente territorio ocupado
los acuerdos de minsk el que se lograron
el 2015 básicamente y que fueron
impulsados por francia y por alemania lo
que suponían era que se otorgará a estas
regiones un estatus de autonomía
especial básicamente y eso suponía una
declaración de cese al fuego alrededor
de esta línea roja que vemos ahí que se
conoce como la línea de contacto y que
es un cese al fuego muy frágil que se ha
violado en múltiples ocasiones tal y
como lo han dicho lo han denunciado
ambas partes en múltiples ocasiones a lo
largo de estos años
y el propio putin dijo tras reconocer la
independencia de estas repúblicas que
los acuerdos de mis básicamente ya no
existen ya no sirven para nada entonces
estamos ante esta nueva situación rusia
ha expedido en esa zona en esas regiones
aproximadamente unos 800 mil pasaportes
de rusos convirtiendo de facto a estas
personas en ciudadanos rusos por lo cual
los comentarios los comentarios del
presidente ruso sobre un supuesto
genocidio por parte del ejército
ucraniano en esa zona pues generaban
tanta preocupación porque justamente
podrían justificar la intervención
militar de rusia justamente para
proteger a los ciudadanos que ya tienen
pues pasaporte ruso y eso es lo que
estamos viendo básicamente hoy pero
andrés vamos días atrás un poco no
porque le pregunto que suponen el
reconocimiento de independencia a estas
repúblicas por parte de rusia por parte
del presidente vladimir putin también
bueno lo primero que estamos viendo
después lo que estamos viendo hoy es
básicamente primero que todo el
despliegue de tropas rusas en la zona
eso que significa el reconocimiento
también supone la posible construcción
de bases militares rusas en esa zona y
eso implica pues el peligro de un
enfrentamiento directo continuo entre
tropas rusas y tropas ucranianas con
pues con todo lo que eso podría implicar
y lo más importante es el tema del de
las reclamaciones territoriales entonces
vamos a volver a observar el mapa y
vemos aquí pues la línea de contacto las
zonas en rojo son las zonas de las
autodenominadas en repúblicas
independientes y en su discurso de
reconocimiento putin aseguró que también
reconoce las reclamaciones territoriales
del 2014 de estos rebeldes que incluyen
no solamente estas zonas sino todas las
regiones de dónetsk y de lugares que son
las partes que vemos un poco en violeta
y en y en amarillo entonces es una
región gente que en totalidad se conoce
como el donbass y que también es
conocido como el cinturón de óxido de
ucrania eso significa que es un enclave
minero un enclave industrial muy
importante para el país económicamente
muy importante y pues justamente ese
reconocimiento supone el peligro de una
extensión de esta invasión rusa hasta a
toda esa región y es que andrea es
occidente habla de una invasión rusa a
gran escala esto quiere decir que
estamos hablando de a largo plazo pues
la única persona que puede responder
realmente esa pregunta es vladimir putin
porque él es quien quien ha creado toda
esta situación en primer lugar pero
tenemos en cuenta que él dijo que
durante semanas que no tenía pensado
invadir sin embargo pues ya envió tropas
lanzó ataques y básicamente lo que
estamos viendo es que estos ataques no
se han limitado únicamente a esta zona
del donbass y calificó esto como una
operación militar especial en el donbass
pero hemos estado registrando como tú lo
has hecho durante toda la mañana ataque
cerca de quiebren odessa en mariupol en
diferentes zonas del país entonces no
estamos hablando de una intervención tan
limitada y la pregunta es qué tanto
querrá rusia implicarse en una
intervención a largo plazo y mucho más
en una ocupación de territorio ucraniano
que hasta ahora el presidente putin pues
ha negado pero estamos hablando de un
país de 44 millones de personas muchas
de ellas hostiles a moscú y
desde una población que es superior a la
de países como irak o afganistán y ya
todos sabemos cómo terminaron esas
intervenciones en los otros países
después de muchos años entonces hace
poco escuchábamos gústame justamente el
presidente selenski haciendo o un
llamado a la población alzarse en armas
controlar contra los rusos y un país con
el que ya rompió relaciones diplomáticas
lo lógico sería pensar que rusia podría
apostarle a una intervención corta o una
acción militar corta para hacerse con el
dominio de estas zonas pero como repito
no se sabe realmente cuál es el alcance
de la operación podría temerse que
incluso pudiera llegar o que el objetivo
final fuera derrocar al gobierno de
bordo diferente y estamos hablando ya en
ese momento andrés como el hemos venido
registrando durante toda esta
transmisión especial de fuerzas
militares le preguntó entonces cómo se
comparan estas fuerzas militares de
ucrania y de rusia podrá que resistir a
todos estos ataques pues es muy difícil
de decir una situación muy complicada
para ucrania tenemos una siguiente
gráfica para poder ilustrar y poder
explicar esta situación la fuerza
ucraniana o mejor dicho la comparación
no no hay comparación posible
básicamente estamos hablando de las
cifras que nos ofrece global fire power
que es una base de datos en temas
relacionados con la defensa a nivel
mundial y que hace el siguiente
comparativo
ucrania tiene un presupuesto militar de
unos 11.800 millones de dólares y rusia-
de 154 mil millones
doscientos mil tropas activas para
ucrania 850 mil para rusia moscú cuenta
con más de cuatro mil aeronaves quiero
con un poco más de 300 entonces como
puede verse ucrania se lleva todas las
de perder en una eventual crisis a largo
plazo de gran escala y obtener el apoyo
del exterior o de países externos pues
va a ser muy complicado y exactamente
ahí quería llegar andrés porque eso se
necesitaría para ganar digamos
públicamente una guerra contra rusia y
porque entonces está difícil que ucrania
reciba ese apoyo militar que necesita
digamos por parte de lo tanto pues para
comprenderlo tenemos que mirar
básicamente las palabras de lo que dijo
vladimir putin cuando anunció esta esta
incursión militar
una de las declaraciones más
preocupantes que hizo el presidente ruso
es la siguiente la vamos a leer quien
intente ponernos obstáculos y más aún
crear amenazas para nuestro país para
nuestro pueblo debe saber que la
respuesta rusa será inmediata agarradera
consecuencias que nunca han
experimentado en su historia estamos
listos para cualquier desarrollo de los
acontecimientos se han adoptado todas
las decisiones necesarias al respecto y
espero que me escuchen estas palabras
cuando salen de la boca de un líder de
un país que según los cálculos tiene más
de 6.000 ojivas nucleares pues genera
enorme preocupación y también supone un
freno casi inmediato para cualquier
incursión militar occidental básicamente
eeuu ha dicho reiteradamente lo dicho el
presidente yo va a ir en que no tiene
planeado enviar tropas a ucrania que no
tiene planeado o que su intención no es
en ningún momento combatir a los rusos
directamente pero y es por eso que
estamos viendo que los países en
occidente están reaccionando a través de
la imposición de una batería de
sanciones que es cada vez más severa a
ver a medida que avanzan pueden ser las
acciones militares de moscú incluso
andrés en estas amenazas del presidente
de la emir putin ha nombrado
precisamente su arsenal nuclear no
nuclear y recordemos también que hizo
ejercicios militares y también nucleares
en estos días como para mostrar
pero putin si le teme algo a la
expansión de la otan le pregunto porque
bueno entonces en efecto se ha sido uno
de los principales temores y ha sido una
de las principales exigencias en materia
de seguridad desde el presidente putin
porque él dice que la otan básicamente
se ha extendido a lo largo de los años
agregando cada vez más países a su
alianza militar y cada vez se ha
acercado más de las fronteras rusas
recordemos que esta alianza a la que se
han unido territorios ex soviéticos
particularmente después de 1997 como por
ejemplo los países bálticos que son
estonia letonia y lituania y es por eso
que esto hace parte de lo que ha exigido
justamente que tiene en materia de
seguridad en estas peticiones que le ha
hecho directamente tanto a la otan como
de eeuu y básicamente estas peticiones
es son no son las siguientes que el
retiro del armamento de la otan de
europa del este y que se prohíba o mejor
dicho que se vete cualquier posibilidad
de un acceso eventual de ucrania a esta
alianza militar ayer justamente al
presidente es el ente que está hablando
en una conferencia de prensa con luces
de presidentes de polonia de lituania y
él el presidente reitera las intenciones
o las aspiraciones de ucrania para
unirse tanto a la unión europea como a
la otan y esto pues supone una línea
roja para moscú no ser miembro de la
otan supone estar bajo el paraguas de
protección de lo que se conoce como el
artículo 5 y esto básicamente dice que
un ataque contra un miembro de la otan
es un ataque contra toda la alianza y
eso obviamente supondría una reacción
militar de la principal superpotencia
que es eeuu y habrá que ver si las
agresiones rusas tienen los efectos
deseados qué es lo que quiere putin
detener esta expansión de la otan o si
por el contrario va no le va a salir
como quiere y va a hacer que al
contrario más naciones quieran unirse a
esta alianza militar justamente para
estar debajo de ese paraguas de
protección con lo cual podría ser el
caso de naciones como finlandia o de
suecia por ejemplo y lo cierto es que
por ahora a pesar de las denuncias de
putin el ingreso a la otan de ucrania no
está sobre la mesa y el verdadero
peligro del que estamos hablando aquí es
como lo decía el secretario general de
la otan es que un mal cálculo pueda
llevar a un enfrentamiento directo entre
rusia y la otan y hablando de
consecuencias catastróficas que
esperemos no reportar las andrés pues ya
todo está sobre la mesa pues es difícil
saber lo que va a pasar como lo dijimos
aquí como lo hemos repetido pues a
medida que pasa el tiempo los minutos y
las horas vamos sabiendo pues lo que va
a pasar ya pues todos los líderes
mundiales están tomando cartas en el
asunto pues militarmente con sanciones
como ya lo hemos venido registrando
gracias andrés por ayudarnos con guantes
de ger entonces pues todo lo que está
pasando y todo el meollo del asunto
andrés muchísimas gracias